let me talk a little bit about I guess
I'm gonna talk about Costa Rica but
really I want to talk about renewable
energy there have been these headlines
circulating that Costa Rica for the last
two months something like nearly 80 days
has been running on 100% renewable
energy this is according to a new report
this is the second time in two years
that Costa Rica has had more than two
months straight on renewable energy
alone they've had 150 days in 2016 total
life without fossil fuels is possible at
least for small countries that's all
really really great okay I am obviously
completely in favor of getting off of
fossil fuels however here's what I
really want to talk about on YouTube
you'll notice that the title to this
video has the term renewable energy in
quotes because when you actually start
looking into the power sources that are
quote renewable in Costa Rica
you realize that it's geothermal it's
wind it's solar but 80% of that
renewable energy in Costa Rica is hydro
power is hydro power really renewable
energy well many people say no and I'll
tell you about some of those people in
general when you're talking about hydro
power you're talking about using the
kinetic energy of flowing water as it
moves downstream to to channel it into
energy that you can harness and use the
water itself is not reduced the water
itself doesn't become used up so in that
sense hydropower is defined as renewable
energy by the EPA the Environmental
Protection Agency
but hydropower is not unanimously
considered renewable because you need
dams for many types of hydropower dams
are very destructive to fisheries they
are destructive to water flows which can
impact fish populations and they have
the water flow disruptions can impact
the sort of sediment table that exists
in and around many of these sources of
water we have seen spawning grounds be
really made more difficult to access
for fish by dams and as a result fish
populations have gone down temperatures
can be impacted water temperatures in
certain areas are impacted by damming so
there is a big movement and I have to
tell you I am sympathetic to this
movement that says you know hydro is not
really renewable and I think that
there's a sort of different way to think
about this it is we can call it
renewable in the sense that it is not
using up a resource the water flows
through and provides energy and then the
water still exists you're not burning up
the water and the way that we are when
we are when we're talking about oil or
coal but it is not sustainable and I
think that's really what makes it for me
a sustainable energy source is one that
is number one renewable but also has
environmental consequences that are not
destructive and in that sense I am
completely on board in saying wait a
second I am all about Costa Rica being
100% on renewable energy but 80% of that
renewable energy is hydro and hydro is
damaging to our planet what do you think
about this you can discuss this with us
on Facebook facebook.com slash David
Pakman show you can also discuss this
with us on reddit at david pakman.com
slash Reddit and of course I'm always
paying attention to my Twitter feed you
can reach me on Twitter at Dee Pakman